were there are certain films in
particular that you watched in terms of
their release and you wanted to model
the cosmonaut after were there certain
ones and dissected and watch what they
did our inspiration at the beginning of
the private were two or three films that
were deemed well that were doing things
differently like age of stupid or Nina
sings the blues and you know a couple of
things that were doing like one of them
were doing creative common release the
other one was crowdfunding form of
angels maybe in a couple more films and
you know watching their model is how we
build ours which put all the good things
we saw in them and we put them together
and build I think a stronger model and
this say it was the same with
crowdfunding we didn't just put the film
on Kickstarter or follow the way they do
parks and things but we invented anyone
which I think was no better one than
what they have because it allowed us to
keep the play alive for three years and
to write more than half a million
dollars which is you know much more than
you usually rise in kickstarter for a
film so those were pretty much the
integration so have you talked to lance
Wyler has he talked to you this is a lot
of this seems like the sort of crosses
over into what he talks about his life
yeah he's being has been one of the main
inspirations we met him at the I think
it was a second power to the pixel and
we fell in love actually our our project
is a transmedia project thanks to him
because a talk we heard about it and and
we i mean i want to say we're friends
but we've been in touch with these years
and and a month ago he invited us to it
frame writers worldwide conference that
is happening in Barcelona which were
really excited about and so yeah we've
been in touch for a while we really
admire everything he did it's amazing he
is very amazing and we saw him at the LA
Film Festival he talked about oh so many
of his ideas were so advanced that it
was hard for people to actually grasp
them yeah yeah dad that's a problem I
mean I think we we were lucky because
you know everything we
we thought about was you know coming out
at the right time not because we decided
that you know because we were lucky so
crowdfunding was a crazy thing three
years ago especially in Spain but
you